the formalities are easily dispensable
for no handshakes in the Premier League
just the odd fist bump but the football
is carrying on for now just come out
from
operation on me lungs and I'm not too
worried about the virus
anyone yes with an underlying health
care no concern is more at risk but
overall yes it could be just away by the
hype at the war winter those charged
with keeping us safe are grappling with
tough decisions could they really advise
the over 70s to stay away from big
gatherings the people at a higher risk
all of these potential interventions we
call them social distancing and some of
them are behavioural around large
gatherings or how we live our daily
lives will be considered next week and
the government is really keen to ensure
that if any advice is made it is
evidence-based and it doesn't
disproportionately disrupt our lives or
businesses the consensus among medical
experts is that we will soon move into
the next phase from containing to
delaying the spread of the virus
I think they've they're going to resist
the urge to just have outright bans in
France for instance they've banned
gatherings larger than 5,000 but that's
very arbitrary it's not based on science
but it does what it does do is it shows
intent by the government in rugby
England's Six Nations game in Italy next
week is off but this afternoon the Welsh
were at Twickenham among the crowd some
Chelsea pensioners embracing change
before we lay on this scale I mean it
could escalate who knows you sanitizer
is ready to go look at that yeah would
you shake my hand or should we fistfight
would shake your head you would then
once we figure out what the danger is
I'm all for cancelling those events you
need to be yeah but once you figure out
I don't think we're there yet
and so for now I think we're fine but if
our we've done it needs to be canceled
and I guess it has to be done the
government will sit down on Monday with
the sports authorities and the
broadcaster's to work out what they need
to do they will be led by the scientific
evidence but also will crucially need to
take the public along with them through
what is uncharted territory the number
of confirmed UK cases is still
relatively small but coronavirus does
have the potential to change the way
that we all live our lives we just don't
know how long that disruption will last
Tom Parmenter sky Neves Twickenham